How are you guys doing? Look at the
weather. What a magnificent and
beautiful day it
is. However, on this beautiful and
magnificent day, I did receive an email
from YouTube and this email was telling
me that the government of
India specifically, not
individuals, not an organization, no,
the actual government of India, the
actual government of a country that's
meant to be one of the superpowers of
the world informed them that they have
banned or they want them and they
complied to YouTube to ban me or my
channel from YouTube in their
country. Now, I know what you're
thinking. This is very unusual. a
country that's one of the strongest
militaries in the world, one of the
biggest countries and nuclear
power. They are concerned, the actual
government is concerned with an
individual who lives in London and who's
criticizing their government.
And as I put up a a community post I put
it up on and also a tweet got lots of I
don't know how many hundreds of
thousands of views or th tens of
thousands of
likes criticizing the Indian government.
I think it was after that that this took
place. Now this shows you is it really
are they really this
fragile? Imagine a government that big.
They're fragile. They're insecure.
They're weak. They're disheartened. They
are demoralized by the criticism of an
individual who lives in London and who's
using his phone right now, okay, to
communicate with the
world.
Unbelievable. But did you think that
this was going to hurt me? Did you think
that you were doing something to me? Did
you think that you are winning? Let me
tell you something and this is my
message okay to the Indian government
since I know that you watch my content
now you can't pretend you can't pretend
you don't watch the champ because you
know you watch the champ yeah you have
to go and complain to YouTube to try and
get my entire channel removed for a
billion people not to see it but I
promise you these people who are
watching using VPN are going to come
across hijab and I believe that this is
going to increase yeah hijab viewing
Muhammad hijab viewing in
India all the way from Bombay to
Hyderabad to this place that place
people are going to be watching hijab
just like they watch Zak night and you
tried to kick him out of the country cuz
once again you're
insecure when I spoke to him one time in
Malaysia he said something beautiful he
said well they can do what they want
because the damage has already been done
and that's what I'm going to say to you
too the damage has already been done.
And not just this, I want you to look at
me very closely as I'm telling you this.
Yes, Modi and other people from the
government which I know you're watching
this. I want you to look at me very
closely as I tell you this. Yeah, you
can't harm me. Look at me very closely.
You can't harm me because if you try you
or any other government because you're
not the first government to try and come
against me this year. You're not the
first government. You're the
first people of the the Dutch government
which I beat in court in a historic
victory tried their best. In fact, they
tried to ban me from 26 European
countries. The Canadian immigration
tried to stop me from coming into
Canada. The US immigration put me under
administrative review so that I don't
easily get a visa into the United States
of America. Can you see a pattern and a
trend here
that it's clear that freedom of speech
for Muslim people has its limitations?
When they see a strong voice, when they
see a convincing voice, when they see
that the narrative is actually starting
to change, they try to ban and censor in
a manner that would be kind of indirect
or that wouldn't seem wouldn't show that
they are their fragility and their
weakness.
But you have already done that. I'm
sorry to say. I'm very very sorry to
say, Modi, you can't hurt me. Neither
can none of your government. Neither can
anybody. With Allah's permission, only
with Allah's permission can I be hurt.
And let me tell you something. What what
can you do? Let me just ask you this
question. Not just to me, but to all of
the Sunni comrades, to the Sunni Muslim
comrades all across the world. Because
Muhammad Hijab by himself is nothing.
It's actually the Sunni Muslim comrades
that are watching this video and that
have been watching me for the last 10
years. Not just me, but other people who
have been advancing the cause of the
Palestinians and the Kashmiris and the
Pakistanis and the Egyptians and this
and that and the other
Muslims. Yes, the Sunni Muslim comrades
all across the
world, they are backing each other.
as the Quran mentions that the believing
men and the believing women that they
are allies to one
another. That's right. And so you can't
take us down because what can you do?
This is my question to India as a
government. Okay. What can you do? What
can you do to Muslim people? I know that
you a lot of you now because you're
Hindutva and you're fascistic and you're
connected with Zionism and you're
friends with Netanyahu and a lot of you
just hate Muslims and this is part of
the ideology of the Hindutva and so on
and so
forth. But I want to ask you a real
question and I want you to think about
this question. What can you actually do?
If you kill us, we're martyrs. If you
imprison us, we're secluded and we are
with Allah subhana t being purified from
our sins. And we believe that that pain
has meaning. And any pain that you
inflict upon us, whether through
imprisonment or otherwise or injury, we
believe that that's a purification of
sins. We believe that that's an
increasing of ranks. So, it's a win-win
situation. Did you think that killing
50,000 people, and this is directed, of
course, to the Zionists in Gaza is
destroying them and beating them and
being victorious over them. Let me tell
you something. Every single one of those
martyrs, 50,000 martyrs in Palestine
that died are victorious already
victorious. You have no victory over
them. You have zero victory. They are
martyrs in our religion. And that's what
the Quran teaches
us that what will make you what kind of
breast bite will you have from us except
one of the two great victories? either
the victory of material success in this
dunya we will have and or the victory of
martyrdom and being sacrificed or
sacrifice for Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
that's why the Muslim is always in a
win-win situation and that's why I want
to tell you you can never harm us you
can never harm hijab you can never harm
the sunni comrades you cannot harm
anybody
because as the prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam told us that
wondrous is the affair of the believer
that all of his affair is
good and this is not to be afforded to
anybody except for the true believer
in if good things happen to him he's
thankful and if bad things happen to him
he is patient and thankful that's why we
become undefeated we become undefeated
beatable. We become undisputed. We
become untouchable. The Muslim who
really believes in these things, you
can't touch us. You can't beat us. Even
if you dropped a thousand nuclear
weapons in Pakistan and Egypt and Turkey
and Iran and you did everything and you
think you killed the Muslims and
defeated them, no, you have made them
all martyrs and you've given them all
victory. So, let me just tell you
something. you already you've already
lost and any attempt that you try you or
your allies because we know now India is
allied with the west and all the
attempts that you try and silencing
people who are lone individuals who are
exercising freedom of speech in their
countries is
a a demonstration of your own
fragility b a a futile and fruitless
effort because it does not harm us as
for the reasons for mentioned and
see
actually a sign of the day of judgment
and that maybe we need an entire
conversation for but I will conclude
with that and I will say my message to
the Indian government you try but you
cannot harm us. fiber I guess.